she got into the van and I had to go
diarrhea right then so I went and went
into her house and had diarrhea while
she was sitting in my parents car and
this is the reality
[Music]
I have a story about my first crush
who's your first crush remember who your
first crush was Cassie yeah she was cute
did I remember Cassie my first crush was
ktt I still remember her short black
hair I've always liked short hair on
women I think it's cool when women do
that you gotta have a pretty face
usually but I like when you know a
girl's like sees what all the other
girls are doing it's like now I'm doing
something different I like that she had
a great smile she had a great sense of
adventure I know that because that's
what I wrote in my diary in fourth grade
she is the great so I don't even know I
still don't know what the that
means a great sense of adventure
and she had a great laugh she had a
booming laugh and now I'm 37 years old I
think about every woman I've ever been
in love with they all had giant laughs I
think really what I need is just
somebody who thinks I'm funny that's or
someone that can pretend that I'm funny
and either way I'm okay with that but I
remember her laugh and she would screw
up my stomach I used to get diarrhea
when she would look at me or she would
twirl her hair or smile at me I mean now
I know that that usually means you know
I like somebody if I get a little
stomach thing but when you're 10 you're
just like what is this how come I have
to take a every time I see Katy
and we would carpool and on Monday
Monday Wednesday Fridays we would pick
up Katie and on Tuesdays and Thursdays
they would pick me up and we would go to
school together at angel elementary
school and I remember one day she was
looking really cute and we picked her up
in our red Chevy lumina and she got in
she got into the van and I had to go
diarrhea right then so I went I went
into her house and had diarrhea while
she was sitting in my parents car and
this is the reality she was just very
sweet she was very nice
I remember her mom was who was just a
bigger Katie she had this big laugh and
she was very generous and kind she would
drive 25 minutes to the Asian market and
she would get these amazing wah sabe
peas and sesame crackers and Katie would
always offer me some of the sesame
crackers and one day she handed me a
whole bag and I took one and I handed it
back said no this is from my mother and
I this is we just want you to have your
own bag and why do I remember this this
was this was 27 years ago and it
affected me so much I'm the youngest of
four nothing was my own if you're from a
big family nothing is yours my winter
jacket was like 23 years old by the time
I got it there was other six cousins and
every sibling there was other things in
the pockets when I got my jacket and I
remember that she gave me my own bag of
sesame crackers this is how this is how
sweet she was and Saturdays I played
soccer now I'm a very competitive person
I I've been fortunate athletically I
played professional tennis for four
years I'm not telling you this to sound
like an asshole I'm telling you this
because it relates to the story Sports
is something I was good at and Katy
shows up to my soccer game with her mom
Saturday morning here comes Katie here
comes her mom this is that this is it
here's the girl I like and here's the
thing I'm good at
I scored six goals that day I scored one
goal as a goalie okay now
do you know how selfish you have to be
with the ball to score as a goalie my
father asked the coach to take me out of
the game
dad's asked the coach to put their son
in the game but this was you know I was
trying to impress Katie okay now in my
house my mom invented this thing called
the special plate okay
the special plate is a real plate that
you eat off of when you achieve
something or you have success this is
not a joke it's a plate it has
balloons on it it says hip-hip-hooray
we're proud of you for being in our
family this is a real thing and when you
score six goals one is a goal that you
get to eat off the special plate okay if
you got an A on your spelling test you
got to eat off the special plate and you
know it sounds great but as you get
older and you experience therapy you go
oh this was kind of up this was
all outcome-based this was all
achievement and success based right and
my dad used to just give himself the
special plate sometimes like I work with
stuff special plate no you can't just
[Laughter]
anyways i scored six one as a goalie and
did you guys hear that it was six one is
it going back there and hold on my mouth
is dry talking about Katie affects me
physically so Monday comes around school
and guess who doesn't give a that I
did six goals one is a goalie Katie's
not impressed didn't even realize it I
don't think you know and this baffles me
I mean as someone that's coming from a
family that's very focused on result and
outcome it frustrated me but now you
know you understand it that wasn't what
her family was into her mom would go
adopt the dogs and bring kids to the
Children's Hospital this wasn't like
their big focus and I was bummed that
she wasn't into it it was
you know her losses I saw it and now
science projects were coming up and this
was this was big because I sat
diagonally from ket and mrs. Kelsey's
fourth-grade anyone else have mrs.
Kelsey yeah and mrs. Kelsey would pair
you up with your science project partner
diagonally that's just how she always
did it okay there's no guarantee but I
felt like it was gonna happen so once I
got paired with Katie we have ample time
together that's great now I had weird
Josh barter sitting to my right and then
annoying Lindsey was across from me okay
and mrs. Kelsey says someone has to make
an announcement in class and Katie
sheepishly walks up to the front of
class and she says she starts to talk
but she can't talk she's crying she's
too sad and she runs to mrs. Kelsey mrs.
Kelsey hugs her and says Katie's mom is
sick and she's in the hospital and
Katie's gonna be missing some school and
it was very sad and we were all sad and
we made one of those giant cards that
you make you know that well the Asian
kid designs it and then everyone else
kind of signs it we sent it off to
Katie's mom and so the next day mrs.
Kelsey's signing science projects but
there's a wrinkle
okay we're Josh barter isn't there okay
turns out he left do you remember the
kid that just left and nobody gave a
no there was there was no cake
there was no card and he was weird Josh
he one time I looked at his backpack and
there was like a shotgun shell in there
and you're like so he's gone so now what
happens I should I should still be
paired up with Katie T but who's with
annoying Lindsey right nobody
so mrs. Kelsey starts pairing us off
okay and she's doing it diagonally thank
God so this is gonna give me some ample
time with Katie t maybe I can figure out
the whole diarrhea thing and she gets to
Katie and maybe it's because Katie's mom
is sick I don't know what it was but she
says - Katie Katie you can pick who you
want if you want to be with Lindsey you
want to be with Michael you know and I'm
like well that's that's you know pretty
but
I'm still confident you know I scored
six goals one is a goalie like why would
she not why would she not pick me I'm
from I'm a Kosta Kosta sir winners
that's how we've been you know we'll eat
off the special played together and Kate
Katy Katy is very happy that she gets to
pick nobody else gets to pick and she
picks Lindsay she picks Lindsay
to be her science project partner
annoying short fat Lindsay and you can't
you could say that then this was 27
years ago where you were allowed to fat
shame so don't think of it from this
year put it through 89 and I was I was
broken I mean I I I can actually feel it
right now and this is crazy to me right
but it it hurt it I felt vulnerable I
didn't even know what that word meant
and I felt that I felt a loss I don't
lose you know I scored six one is a
goalie and it ended I didn't know what
to do
I'm ten also don't forget that I'm Ted
and I'm feeling rejected and I'm feeling
hurt and I took that pain
and I took that rejection and I took
that feeling that I did not like and was
uncomfortable with and I spoke and I
said as loud as I could to her and
everyone I said I hope your mom dies in
the hospital
this now now I know but but then this
was the first of many times where my
mouth would get me in a lot of trouble
okay I mean Here I am at a strip club
telling a story to strangers so and it
was it was a terrible thing to say and
as soon as I said it Katie
withered and she became aspect she she
started crying she had never seen
anybody so physically hurt and mrs.
Kelsey sent her down to the nurse's
office I was sent down to the
principal's office I walked real slow
down there you know but now it makes me
think of when I tell my dog to go into
the cage and you kind of like you know
now we all remember walking down to the
principal's office and even I at ten
remember thinking like god that was that
was dick you know and I sat in the
principal's office and I saw Katie with
the nurse and she was broken I had I had
broken her I had taken my pain and I had
multiplied it by a thousand and I had
dumped it on her and it it's worse than
that because three days later Katie's
mother dies in the hospital this is not
a joke this is not written this is real
this is a real story and I have not
spoken to Katie since then I regret that
I said that I've never apologized to her
or her family and I realize it's a
little self-indulgent to put pain on
someone and then use it as a performance
piece to advance my comedy career
but that's not what this is I'm publicly
here to say to Katie that I'm sorry and
to her family I'm sorry and I regret
that I ever said that thank you very
much